The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: Welcome to
the final week of 6.046.
Are you excited?
[CHEERING]
Yeah, today--
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ERIK DEMAINE: Well,
and sad, I know.
It's tough.
But we've got two more lectures.
They're on that one topic, which
is cache oblivious algorithms.
And this is a
really cool concept.
It was actually
originally developed
in the context of 6.046, as
sort of an interesting way
to teach cache-efficient
algorithms.
But it turned into a
whole research program
in the late '90s, and
now it's its own thing.
It's kind of funny to
bring it back to 6.046.
The whole idea is in all of
the algorithms we have seen,
except maybe
distributed algorithms,
we've had this view that all
of the data that we can access
is the same cost.
If we have an array,
like a hash table,
accessing anything in a hash
table is equally costly.
If we have a binary
search tree, every node
costs the same to access.
But this is not real.
Let me give you
some idea of what
a real computer looks like.
You probably know this, but
we've not yet thought about it
in an algorithmic context.
These are caches, what are
typically called caches,
in your computer.
Then you have what we've
mostly been thinking about,
which is main memory, your RAM.
And then there's
probably more stuff.
These days you probably
have some big flash.
If you have a
fancier computer, you
have flash, which
is maybe caching
your disk, which is huge.
And then maybe there's
the internet at the end,
if you like.
So the point is all the data in
the world is not on your CPU.
And there's this big thing which
is called the memory hierarchy,
which dictates which
things are fast
and which things are
slow, not exactly which
data items; that's up to you.
But the idea is that
on board your CPU
you have probably, these days,
up to four levels of cache.
As I've tried to draw them,
they get increasingly big.
Typical values--
a level one cache
is something on the order
of 10, 32 K, whatever.
Level four cache these
days, as introduced
by like Haswell Architectures,
has about 100 megabytes.
Main memory you know; this is
the thing you usually think.
About.
It's in the gigabytes.
These days you can buy computers
with a terabyte of RAM.
It's not crazy.
Flash gets bigger.
Disk-- these days you can
buy 4-terabyte single disk,
but if you have a
whole RAID of disks,
you can have petabytes
of data on one computer.
So things are getting bigger
as we go farther to the right.
But they're also
getting slower. .
And the point of cache
efficient algorithms
is to deal with the fact
that things get slow
when they get far away.
And this makes sense from
a physics standpoint.
If you think about
how much data can
you store in a cubic
inch or something
and how much could possibly be
near your CPU, at some point,
you're just going
to run out of space,
and you've got to
go farther away.
And to go farther away is
going to take more time.
So you can think of
it-- I mean, there's
the speed of light
argument, that things
that are farther
away in your computer
are going to take longer.
Typical computers
are not anywhere near
the speed of light, so there's
a more real issue, which
is how long are your traces.
And then when you have physical
moving parts, like a disk,
I don't know if you know,
but disks actually spin,
and there's a head, and
it has to move around.
And that's called seek time.
Moving a head around on
the disk is really slow,
on the order of milliseconds.
Whereas reading
from on-chip cache,
that's on the order
of nanoseconds,
whatever your clock rate is, so
a few billion times a second.
So there's a big
spread of like a factor
of a million or 10 million from
level one cache to disk speed.
That sucks.
And so you might think,
well, if your data's big,
you're just screwed.
You've got to deal with
disk, and disk is slow.
But that's not true.
Life is not so bad.
So, in general, there's
two notions of speed,
and I've been kind
of vague on them.
One notion is latency,
which is if right now I
have the idea that I really
need to fetch memory location 2
billion and 73, how long does
it take for that data-- say,
one word of data-- to come back?
That's latency.
But there's another
issue, which is bandwidth;
how fat are these pipes?
What's my rate of information
that I could pump?
If I said, please give me
all of main memory in order,
how fast could it pump it back?
And that's actually really good.
So latency is like
your start up cost.
When I ask for
something, how long
does it take for that
one thing to come?
But then there's a data rate.
And bandwidth you can
generally make really large.
For example, in disk, bandwidth
of a disk is pretty big.
But even if it weren't big, you
could just add 100 more disks.
And then when you
ask for some data,
all 100 disks could give
you data at the same speed,
and provided you don't
overload your bus,
so you've got to also
make more buses and so on.
You can actually really huge
amount of data per second,
but still the time to get there
and the time for all the disks
to seek their
heads, that's slow.
It doesn't add up, actually,
because they're all
doing it in parallel.
So you can't reduced latency,
but you can increase bandwidth.
And let's say-- it
doesn't match physics,
but we can get pretty close
to arbitrarily high bandwidth.
And so in a
well-designed computer,
the fatnesses of
these pipes are going
to increase, or could
increase, if you want.
So you can move
lots of data around.
But latency we can't get
rid of, and this is annoying
because from an algorithmic
standpoint, when
we ask for something,
we'd like it immediately.
In a sequential logarithm,
we can't do anything
until that date arrives.
So cache efficiency is going
to fix this by blocking.
This is an old idea, since
caches were introduced.
There's the idea of blocking.
So when you ask for a
single word in main memory,
you don't get one word.
You get maybe 32
kilobytes of information,
not just 4 bytes or 8 bytes.
And we're kind of free to
choose these block sizes however
we want, when we
designed the system.
So we can set them, in a
certain sense, to hide latency.
So if you think of amortizing
the cost over the block,
then you have something like
amortized cost over block.
This is per word.
Essentially, we divide the
latency by the block size.
And we have to pay
one over bandwidth.
Bandwidth is how
many words a second
you can read, say,
from your memory.
So one over bandwidth is
going to be your cost.
So this we can't change but.
By adding enough disks
or adding enough things
at making these
pipes fat enough,
you can basically make this big.
Latency is the thing
we can't control.
But if this block
is sort of useful,
then we're paying the initial
start up time, say, hey,
give me this block, and then
waiting for the response.
That latency we only pay
once for the entire block.
So if there are block-size
words in that block, per item,
we're effectively dividing
latency by block size.
This is kind of rough,
but this is the idea
of how to reduce latency.
Now, for this actually work,
we need better algorithms.
Pretty much every algorithm you
see in the class so far works
horribly in this model.
So that's the point of today
and next class is to fix that.
For this kind of
amortization to work,
I'm using "use" in a
vague sense so far.
We'll make it
formal in a moment.
When I fetch an entire
block, all of the elements
in that block should be useful.
We should be able to
compute something on them
that we needed to compute.
Otherwise, if I if I only needed
the one item that I read out
of the block, that's not
going to help me so much.
So I really want to structure
my data in such a way
that when I access
one element, I'm
also going to access
the elements nearby it.
Then this blocking will
actually be useful.
This is a property normally
called spatial locality.
And the other thing
we'd like-- these caches
have some size, so I can store
more than just one block.
It's not like I read
one block, and I just
finish processing it, and then
I read the next block and go on.
Some of these caches
are actually pretty big.
If you think of main memory
as a cache to your disk,
that can be really big.
So ideally, the blocks
that I'm using here
relate to each
other in some way,
or when I access
the block, I'm going
to access it for awhile,
along with other blocks.
So the way this
is usually said is
that we'd like to reuse the
existing blocks in the cache
as much as possible.
And this you can think
of as temporal locality.
When I access a
particular block,
I'm going to access
it again fairly soon.
That way it's actually useful
to bring it into my cache,
and then I use it many times.
That would be even better.
I don't have to
have both of these,
and exactly to
what extent I have
them is going to dictate
what the overall time
it's going to take
to run my algorithm.
But these are so
the ideal properties
you want in a very
informal sense.
Now, in the rest today, we're
going to make this formal,
and then we're going to develop
some algorithms for this model.
But this is the motivation.
In reality, we're free to
choose block size in the system.
Though, in a moment,
I'm going to assume that
it's given to us.
You'd normally
set the block size
so that these two terms
come out roughly equal.
Because if you're spending
the latency time to go and get
something, you might as well
get a whole chunk of something,
according to whatever
your bandwidth is.
If it only cost
you, say, twice as
much to fetch an entire
block than to fetch one word,
that seems like a
pretty good block size.
So for something like
disk, that block size
is on the order of
megabytes, maybe even
bigger-- hundreds of megabytes.
So think of the block
sizes as really big.
We really want all that data
to be useful in some way.
Now it's really hard
to think about a memory
hierarchy with so many levels.
So we're going to focus
on two levels at a time--
the sort of the
cheap and small cache
versus the huge thing,
which I'll call disk,
just for emphasis.
So I'm going to call
this two-level model
the external memory model.
It was originally
introduced as a model
for main memory versus disk.
But you could apply it
to any pair of levels.
In general, you have
your problem size N,
choose the smallest level
that fits N. Typically that's
main memory.
Maybe it's disk.
And just think of the level
between that and the previous,
so the last level and
the next to last level.
Often that's what matters.
Like if you run a program,
and you run out of RAM,
and you start swapping the
disks, that's when everything
just slows to a crawl.
You can see that difference
at each of these levels,
but it's probably
most dramatic at disk
just because it's so slow-- a
million times slower than RAM,
or at least 1,000 times
slower than RAM, I should say.
Anyway, so we have
just two levels.
So let me draw a
more precise picture.
We have the CPU.
This is where all
of our operations
are doing this, where we
add numbers and so on.
We'll think of it as having a
constant number of registers.
Each register is one word.
And then we have a really
fat pipe, low latency pipe,
to the cache.
Cache is going to be
divided into blocks.
So let's say there's
B words per blocks.
Instead of writing
block size, I'll
just write capital B.
And the number of blocks.
I'm going to call M over B. So
the total size of your cache
is capital M. And then there
is a relatively thin and slow
connection-- this one's fast.
This one's slow-- to your disk.
Disk we'll think of as huge,
essentially infinite size.
It's also divided into blocks
of size B, so same block size.
So this is the picture.
And so, initially,
all of the input
is over here, all of your
end data items, whatever.
So you want to sort those items.
And in order to
access those items,
you first have to
bring them into cache.
That's going to be slow, but
it's done in a blocked manner.
So when I can't access
an individual item here,
I have to request
the entire block.
When I request that block,
it gets sent over here.
It takes a while.
And then I get to choose
where to store it.
Maybe I'll put it here.
And then maybe I'll
grab this block
and then store it
here and so on.
Each of those is a block read,
so these are new instructions
the CPU can do.
And eventually, this
cache will get full.
And then before I
bring in a new block,
I have to kick out an old lock.
Meaning I need to
take one these blocks
and write it to some position,
maybe to the same place.
I think, in fact, we
will always assume
that you write to the
same place, overwrite
what was on the disk.
You made some changes
here, send it back.
And, in general, what
we're going to do
is count how many times
we read and write blocks.
Question?
AUDIENCE: When you talked about
how fast the connection is,
you're just talking
about latency, right?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes,
sorry, this is latency.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so like
the [INAUDIBLE] connections
[? just don't have ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Right, this
could have huge bandwidth.
So in this model, we're assuming
the block size is fixed,
and then the latency
versus bandwidth
is not-- we're not going
to think about bandwidth.
We'll assume the
block size has been
chosen in some reasonable way.
And then all we need to do is
count the number of blocks.
But underneath, yeah, you
have some kind of bandwidth.
Presumably you
set the block size
to make these two
things roughly equal,
and so then latency
and bandwidth
are kind of the same thing.
That's the idea.
But really, we're just going to
think about counting latency,
which is how many
times do I have
to request to block and
wait for it to come over,
and how much does it
cost to write a block?
How many times do
I write a block?
I'm not going to worry about
how much physical time it
takes me to do either
of those things;
I'm just going to count
them and assume that that
is what I need to minimize.
So I'm going to count-- we
call these memory transfers--
transfers of blocks
between levels,
between these two levels.
This is the number of blocks
read from or written to disk.
We're going to view accesses
to the cache as free.
I'm not going to count those.
You don't need to
worry about that
so much because we can still
count the number of operations
that we do on the
computer, on the CPU.
We still can think
about how much time,
regular time, it takes
to do the computation--
how many comparisons, how many
additions, things like that.
And that would include things
like reading and writing
elements from cache--
individual things.
But we're going to view
this connection-- let's say,
these are on the same ship.
So reading cache is just as
fast as reading from registers.
So we're not going to
worry about that time.
What we're focusing on, for
the purpose of this model,
is between these two levels.
So these are essentially
one level combined.
I'll change that
in a little bit.
But for now, just think
about the two levels.
And we're counting how
many memory transfers
do we have between these
two levels, cache and disk.
So we want to minimize that.
Now, just like before,
we want to minimize
the running time in the
usual traditional measure.
And we want to minimize space
and all the usual things
we minimize.
But now we have a
new measure, which
is number of memory transfers,
and we want our algorithm
to minimize that too,
for a given block size
and for a given cache size.
And at this point-- I'm going
to change this in a moment--
the algorithm that we would
write in this external memory
model explicitly
manages the blocks.
It has to explicitly
read and write blocks.
And there's a
software system that
implements this model,
particularly for disk,
and lets you do this in
a nice controlled way,
maintain your memory, maintain
reading and writing disk.
The operating system
tries to do this,
but it usually does a really
bad job with swapping.
But there are
software systems that
let you take control
and do much better.
So that's a good model.
External memory model is
especially good for disk.
It's not going to capture
the finesse of all
these other levels, and
it's a little bit annoying
to write algorithms in
this way-- explicitly
reading and writing blocks.
Today I will not write
any such algorithms.
Although, you could
think about them.
I personally love
this other model,
which is cache obviousness.
It's going to lead to, in
some sense, cleaner algorithm.
Although, it's more of a magic
trick to get them to work.
But writing the
algorithms is very simple.
Analyzing them is more work.
And it will capture, in some
sense, all of these levels.
But, in fact, it is basically
exactly this model, almost
the same.
We're going to change
one thing, which is
where the oblivious comes from.
We're going to say that
the algorithm doesn't
know the cache parameters.
It doesn't know B or M.
So this is a little weird.
We're going to have to make some
other changes to make it work.
From an analysis perspective, I
want to count memory transfers
and analyze my algorithm
with respect to this memory
hierarchy.
But the algorithm
itself isn't allowed
to know what that member
hierarchy looks like.
Another way to say this
is that the algorithm
has to work simultaneously
for all values of B
and all values of M.
As you might imagine,
this is not so easy.
But there are some simple
things where this is easy,
and more complicated things
where this is possible.
And it gives you all
sorts of cool things.
Let me first formalize
the model a little bit.
The other nice thing about
cache oblivious algorithms
is it corresponds
much more closely
to how these caches work.
When you write code
on your CPU, you
may have noticed
you don't usually
do block reads and block
writes, unless you're
dealing with flash or disk.
All of this is
taking care for you.
It's all done internal
to the processor.
When you access a word,
behind the scenes,
magically, the
system, the computer,
finds which word to read
or which block to read.
It moves the entire block
into a higher level cache,
and then it's just serving
you words out of that block.
And you don't have
explicit control over that.
So the way that works is when
you access a word in memory--
and I'm going to think
of memory as everything;
this is what's stored
in the disk, say.
This is the entire memory
system, the entire memory
hierarchy.
And, as usual in
this class, we're
going to think of
the entire memory
as a giant array of words.
Each of these
squares is one word.
But then also, the memory
is now divided into blocks.
So let's say every four.
Let's say B equals 4.
Every four words is
a block boundary,
just for the sake
of drawing a figure.
So this is B equals 4.
When you access a single
word, like this one,
you get the entire block
containing the word.
Let's say, to emphasize,
it's not you personally;
the system somehow fetches the
block containing that word.
It has to do this automatically.
We can't explicitly read and
write blocks in this model
because we don't know
how big the blocks are.
So it couldn't even name them.
But internally, on the real
system and in your analysis,
you're going to think of
whenever you touch something,
you actually get all
this into the cache.
So you hope that you will use
things nearby because you've
already read them in.
Ideally, they're useful.
But you don't know how
many you've read in.
You've read in B, and
you don't what B is.
The algorithm doesn't now.
One more detail--
the cache is going
to get full pretty quickly.
And so then, whenever
you read something,
you have to kick something out.
In steady state,
cache might as well
always stay full-- no reason
to leave anything empty.
So which block do you kick out?
Any suggestions?
Which block should I kick out?
If I've been reading
and writing some blocks,
reading and writing to
words within these blocks.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: The block that was
fetched farthest in the past?
Yeah that is usually
called First In, First Out.
That's FIFO.
And that is a good strategy.
Any other suggestions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: The block has
been least recently used.
So maybe you fetched
it a long time ago,
but you use it
every clock cycle.
That one you should
probably not throw away
because you use it a lot.
That's called LRU, and that
is also a good strategy.
Other suggestions?
Those are two good ones.
If you go beyond that,
I'm worried I won't know.
But there are some
bad strategies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just random.
ERIK DEMAINE: Random-- yeah,
random is probably pretty good.
I don't know offhand.
There are some
randomized strategies
that beat both of those.
But from this perspective,
both are good.
We've got lots of Frisbees
to go through, so.
That's a good answer.
Random is definitely
a good idea.
I know there's a randomized
strategy called [? bit, ?]
that in certain senses
is a little bit better.
But from my perspective, I
think all of those are good.
Random, I have to double check
whether you lose a log factor.
And expectation should be fine.
So all of those
strategies will work.
You could define this
model with any of them.
I think it would work
fine, except randomize,
you'd get an expectation bound.
So the system evicts, let's say,
the least recently used page.
The least recently loaded
page would also work fine.
That's FIFO.
Sorry I'm switching to page, but
I've been calling them blocks.
Blocks and pages are the
same thing for this lecture.
And either at the end of this
lecture or beginning of next,
I'll tell you why
that's an OK thing.
But let's not worry
about it at this point.
So now we have a model--
cache flow oblivious.
We have two models, actually.
But I think now that
the cache flow oblivious
model is complete,
we're going to analyze.
Again, we're still counting
the number of memory transfers
in this thing.
The algorithm's just not
allowed know B and M,
and so we had to
change the model
to make the reading
and writing of blocks
automatic because
the algorithm's not
allowed to do it.
So someone's got to.
The cool thing about
cache oblivious model
is every algorithm
you see in this class,
or most of the algorithms
are in a certain sense
cache oblivious algorithms.
They weren't aware of B
and M before, still not.
What changes is now you can
analyze them in this new way,
in this new model.
Now, as I said, all the
algorithms we've seen
are not going to perform well
in this model-- almost all.
But that makes
things interesting,
and that's why we
have some work to do.
I have some reasons why
cache obliviousness--
why would you tie your
hands behind your back
and not know B or M?
Reason one, it's cool.
I think it's pretty amazing
you can actually do this.
I guess that's reason
two is you can actually
do it for a lot of
problems we care about.
Cache oblivious algorithms
exist that are just as good.
So, I mean, of
course they exist.
But there are ones
that are optimal.
They're within a constant
factor of the best algorithm
when you know B or M.
So that's surprising.
That's the cool part.
In general, the
algorithms are easier
to write down because we can use
pseudo code just like before.
We don't need to worry about
blocking in the algorithm.
The analysis is going to be
harder, but that's unavoidable.
In some sense, it makes
it easier to write code.
And it's also a little easier
to distribute your code
because every computer
has different block
sizes that matter.
Also, as you change
your value of N,
a different level in the memory
hierarchy's going to matter.
And so it's annoying-- each of
these levels, I didn't mention,
has a different block
size and, of course,
has a different cache size.
So tuning your code every
time to a different B or M
is annoying.
The big gain here,
though, I think,
is that you capture the
entire hierarchy, in a sense.
So in the real world,
each of these pipes
has its own latency.
And let's just
think about latency.
And you'd like to minimize
the number of block transfers
between here and here.
You'd like to minimize the
number block answers here here.
Well, OK, I can't
minimize all of them.
That's a
multi-dimensional problem.
What I'd like to minimize
is some weighted average
of those things-- latency
times number of blocks here,
plus the latency times
the number of blocks
here, plus latency times
here, and so on.
If you can find an optimal cache
oblivious algorithm and analyze
it just with respect
to two levels,
because the algorithm's not
allowed to know B and M,
it has to work for all levels.
It has to minimize the number
of block transfers between all
these levels, and
so, in particular,
will minimize the
weighted sum of them.
It's a bit hand wavy.
You have to prove
something there.
But you can prove it.
So there's a paper
about this from 1999
by Frigo, Leiserson,
Prokop, and Ramachandran.
It's old enough that I
remember all the names.
After about 2001, when
I became a professor,
I can't remember anything.
But before that, I can
remember everything.
So Frigo, we've talked about
him in the context of FFTW.
That was the fastest Fourier
Transform in the West.
So he was a student here.
And FFTW uses a cache oblivious
Fast Fourier Transform
algorithm.
Leiserson, you've probably seen
on the cover of your textbook
or walking around Stata.
Professor Leiserson here at MIT.
And Prokop, this is actually
his [? M Enge ?] thesis.
So pretty awesome
[? M Enge ?] thesis.
All right, so cool, I
think I said all the things
I wanted to say.
So if you want to see
the proof that you
can solve the entire
memory hierarchy,
you can read their paper.
You have to make a
couple of assumptions,
but it's intuitive.
Cache oblivious has to
work for all B and M,
so it's going to optimize all
the levels simultaneously.
Doing that explicitly, with all
the different B's and M's, that
would be really messy
code, probably also slower.
Cache oblivious is
just going to do it
for free with the same code.
All right, let's
do some algorithms.
There's one easy
algorithm which works
great from a cache oblivious
perspective, which is scanning.
Let we give you
some Python code.
For historical
reasons, in this field,
N is written with
a capital letter.
Don't ask, or don't
worry about it.
So here's some very simple code.
Suppose you want to
accumulate an array.
You want to add up all
of the items in the array
or multiply them or take
them in or whatever.
This is a typical kind of thing.
Again, an array, we're
going to think of-- so here
was my memory.
We're going to
think of the array
as being stored
as some contiguous
segment of that array,
let's say, this segment.
So this is important.
Assume array is stored
contiguously, no holes,
relative to how it's
mapped on to memory.
And this is a
realistic assumption.
When you allocate
a block of memory,
the promise by the system
is that it's essentially
a contiguous chunk of
memory or disk, or whatever.
And when Python makes
an array, it does this.
It guarantees that these things
will be stored contiguously.
If you use a dictionary,
this would not be true.
But for regular [? array's ?]
list, this is true.
So I'm accessing the items
in the array in order,
and so I start
here at item zero.
I end up with item N minus 1.
That seems good because
I read this one.
I get the whole block.
Then I read this one.
I already had that block.
It's free.
This one's free.
Here I have to read a new block.
But then this one's free.
So the first item I
access in each block
costs one, but as long as my
cache store's at least one
block, that's enough.
And let's say the
sum is a register;
that's enough to
remember that block so
that the next operation
I do will be free.
So the cost is going
to be-- actually,
be a little more precise--
ceiling of N over B almost.
Without the big O here, this
is right in the external memory
model, but not quite right
in the cache oblivious model.
Can someone tell me why?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If N is
two, you could have it
beyond a border [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Good,
N could be two.
But it could span
a block boundary.
Remember, the
algorithm has no idea
where the block boundaries are.
And again, in reality,
there are block boundaries
all over the place, and
there's no way to know.
You can't request that
when you allocate an array
it always begins in
a block boundary.
So great, you can span block
boundaries in-- oh, way off.
I just spanned a
block boundary, sorry.
So it's going to be,
at most, ceiling over N
over B plus 1 cache obviously.
So it's just going
to hurt you by one.
But I want to point out,
there's a slight difference
between the two models,
even with this very simple
algorithm.
In general, I'm just
going to think of this
as big O N over B plus 1.
There's some additive constant.
I guess you could even say
it's N over B plus big O 1,
but we won't worry about
constant factors today.
So that's scanning, cache
oblivious external memory,
both great.
Slightly more interesting--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, in the
external memory algorithm,
because you're explicitly
controlling the blocks,
you're explicitly
reading and writing them.
And you know where the
block boundaries are.
You could, if you wanted
to, you don't have to,
but you could choose
the array to be aligned,
to be starting at
a block boundary.
So that's the distinction.
In the cache oblivious,
you can't control that,
so you have to worry
about the worst case.
External memory you
could control it,
and you could do better,
and maybe you'd want to.
It will hurt you buy
a constant factor.
And in disks, for
example, you want
things to be track
aligned because if you
have to go to an adjacent track,
it's a lot more expensive.
You've got to move the head.
Track is a circle, what
you can read without moving
the head, so great.
So slightly more
interesting is you
can do a constant number
of parallel scans.
So that was one scan.
Here's an example of two scans.
Again, we have one array
of size N. Python notation,
that would be the whole thing.
And what I want to do is swap
Ai with-- this is not Python,
but it's, I think,
textbook notation.
But you know what swap means.
What does this do, assuming
I got my minus ones right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It reverses the array.
ERIK DEMAINE: It
reverses the array, good.
We'll just run through
these Frisbees.
So this is a very
simple algorithm
for reversing the array.
It was originally
by John Bentley,
who was Charles
Leiserson's adviser-- PhD
adviser-- back in the day.
So very simple, but
what's cool about it,
if you think about the array
and the order in which you're
accessing things, it's
like I have two fingers--
and I should have
made this smaller.
So here, we'll go down here.
I start at the very
beginning of the array
and the very end of the array.
Then I go to the second
element, next to last element,
and I advance like this.
So as long as your cache M, the
number of blocks in the cache
is at least two, which
is totally reasonable.
You can assume this is
at least 100, typically.
You've got at least
100 blocks, say.
So for any fixed constant,
we're going to assume N over B
is bigger than a constant.
We'll only need like
two or three or four
for the algorithms we cover.
Then great, when I
access this item,
I will load in the
block that contains it.
I don't know how it's aligned,
but don't care so much.
And then I load in the block
that contains this item.
And then the next
accesses are free until I
advance to the next block.
But once I advance to the next
block on the left or the right,
I'll never have to
access the old ones.
And so again, the
cost here is just
going to be equal to the
number of blocks, which
is big O of N over B plus 1.
So a constant number
of parallel scans
is going to be basically the
number of blocks in the array.
So N is smaller than B, this
is a bad idea or not so hot.
But when N is
bigger than B, this
is just N over B.
That's how much it takes
to read in the data-- big deal.
So these are boring cache
oblivious algorithms.
Let's do interesting ones.
And I would say the
central idea in cache
oblivious algorithms is
to use divide-and-conquer.
This goes back to the first
few lectures in this class.
And so we will go back
to examples from there.
Today we're going to
do the median finding,
in particular, which
we did in lecture two,
so really a blast from the past.
But it's good review because
the final covers everything,
so you've got to remember that.
Matrix multiplication,
we've talked about, but not
usually-- well, I guess we did
actually use divide-and-conquer
for Strassen's algorithm.
We're going to use -and-conquer
even for the boring algorithm
today.
And then next class, we're going
to go back to van Emde Boas,
but in a completely
different way.
So if you don't
like van Emde Boas,
don't worry; it's much simpler.
So let's do median finding.
Or actually, sorry, let me first
talk about divide-and-conquer
in general.
You know what
divide-and-conquer is.
You take your problem.
You split it into
non-overlapping subproblems,
recursively solve
them, combine them.
But what I want
to stress here is
what it's going to look like
in a cache oblivious context.
So the algorithm
is going to look
like a regular
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
So, in particular, the algorithm
will recurse all the way to,
let's say, constant
size problems,
whatever the base case is.
So same as usual, but what's
different is the analysis.
When we analyze a cache
oblivious algorithm,
then we get to know
what B and M are.
In some sense, we're
analyzing for all B an M.
But let's suppose B
and M is given to us,
then will tell you how many
memory transfers you need.
This kind of bound,
you need to know
what B is to know what the
value of this bound is.
But you learn it as a
function of B and, in general,
a function of B
and M, and that's
the best you could hope for as
a complete characterization.
So in the analysis, let's
just look at one value of B
and one value of M. So
analysis knows B and M,
and it's going to look at,
let's say, the recursive level,
where one of two things happens.
Either the problem size
fits in order one blocks.
So meaning it's order B size.
That's an interesting level.
Another interesting level,
the more obvious one probably,
is that it fits in cache.
So that means that the size is
less than or equal to capital
M. Everything here is
counted in terms of words.
This is the more obvious one.
For a lot of problems, the
cache size isn't so relevant.
What really matters
is the block size.
For example, scanning, you're
only looking through the data
once.
So it doesn't matter
how big your cache is,
as long as it's not super tiny.
As long as it has
a few blocks, then
it's just a function of
B and N, no M involved.
So for that kind of
problem this would
be more useful-- constant
number of blocks.
Because I think of the
cache M as being larger
than any constant times B,
this is strictly smaller,
or this is smaller or equal
to problem fitting in cache.
So when M is
relevant, we'll look
at this level and maybe
the adjacent levels
in the recursion.
So the algorithm doesn't know
what B and M are, so it's
got to recurse all
the way down-- turtles
all the way down.
But the analysis,
because we're only
thinking about one
value B and M at a time,
we can afford to just
consider that one level,
and that will be like
the critical place
where all the cost is.
Because once things fit in cache
and you've loaded things in,
the cost will be zero.
So below that, the base
case is kind of trivial.
So basically what
this is going to do
is make our base cases larger.
Instead of our base
case being constant,
it's going to be order B or M.
What don't I need?
So now let's going
to median finding.
Median finding, you're
given an unsorted array.
You want to find the median.
And in lecture two,
we had a linear time
worst case algorithm for this.
And so my goal today is to
make it this running time.
This is what you
might call linear time
in the cache oblivious model
because that's how long it
takes just to read the data.
It turns out basically
the same algorithm works.
First, you've got to
remember the algorithm.
So let me write it down quickly.
This is the sort of
five by in N array.
So think of the array as
being partitioned into, I'll
call them, five columns.
So this picture of five dots
by N over 5 dots-- this is
dot, dot, dot.
So this is five.
Now, we didn't
talk about it then,
and there's a few different
ways you could actually
implement it, but let's say
these-- the actual array is
one-dimensional.
Let's say these are
the first five items.
These are the next five items.
So, in other words, this matrix
is stored column-by-column.
This is just a conceptual view.
So we can define it either
way, however we want.
So I'm going to
view it that way.
And then what the rest of the
algorithm did was for sort
each column, it's
only five items,
so you can sort it in
constant time, each one.
But, in particular,
what we care about
is the median of
those five items.
Then we recursively found
the median of the medians.
This is the step we're going
to have to change a little bit.
Then we-- leave a
little bit of space.
Then we partition
the array by x.
Meaning we split the
array into items less than
or equal to x and
things greater than x.
We probably assumed there was
only one value equal to x,
but it doesn't matter.
And finally, we recurse on
one of those two halves.
So this is a pretty crazy
divide-and-conquer algorithm,
one of the more
sophisticated ones.
You don't need to know
all the details here,
just that it worked and
it ran in linear time.
What's crazy about it is
there are two recursive calls.
Usually, like in
merge sort, where
you do two recursive calls
and spend linear time
to do the stuff,
like this partition,
you get n log n time,
like merge sort.
Here, because this
array is a lot smaller,
this is a size N over 5.
And this one was
reasonably small;
it was like [? M of ?] 7/10
N. Because 7/10 plus 1/5
is strictly less than
1, this ends up being
linear time instead of n log n.
That's just review.
Now, what I'd like to do is
the same thing, same analysis,
or same algorithm, but
now I want to analyze it
in this two-level model.
So actually, I will
erase this board.
So now my array has been
partitioned into blocks
of size B, like this picture.
In fact, it's quite similar.
Here, we're partitioning
things into blocks,
but they're size five.
That's different.
Now someone has partitioned my
array into blocks of size B.
I need to count how
many things I access.
Well, let's just look
line-by-line at this code
and see what we do.
Step one, we do
absolutely nothing.
This is a conceptual
picture, so zero cost, great.
Step one is zero,
my favorite answer.
Step two, we sort each column.
How long does this take?
What am I doing?
It's right above me.
AUDIENCE: N over B.
ERIK DEMAINE: N over B
because this is a scan.
It's a little bit
weird of a scan.
We look at five
items, and then we
look at the next five items,
and then the next five items.
But it's basically a scan.
You could think of it as almost
five parallel scans, I suppose,
or you could just
break into the case
where maybe if B
is a constant, then
it doesn't matter what you do.
But if B bigger than a constant,
then reading five items,
those are all probably
going to be in one block,
except the ones that straddle
the block boundaries.
So in all cases,
for step two-- maybe
I should rewrite
step one-- zero cost.
Step two, is order N over
B plus 1, to be careful.
That's a scan.
Actually, it's
two parallel scans
because we have to write
out these medians somewhere,
so we'll have to.
Step three is recursively
find the medians.
Now, before, we had in
T of N is T of N over 5
plus T of 7/10 N plus linear.
In this new world-- this
is regular running time.
In this new world,
I'm going to use
a different notation for
the recurrence, MT of N
for memory transfers.
This is a good
old-fashioned time,
and this is our new
modern notion of time--
how many block transfers do I
need to do for problem size N.
So this is a recursion, and
should be MT of N over 5.
But, and this is
important, for this
to be a same problem
of the same type,
I need to know that the
array that recursing on
is stored contiguously.
Before, I didn't
need to do that.
I could say, well, let's put
the medians in the middle.
So now every fifth item in
this array is my new subarray.
And so I could recursively
call this thing
and say, OK, here's my
array, but really only think
about every fifth item.
That's like a
stride in the array.
And then the next
recursive level, oh, only
worry about every 25th item.
And every 5-cubed item, I'm
going to stop computing,
and so on.
And that would be fine
for regular running time.
But when I get my stride
gets bigger and bigger,
at some point,
every item is going
to be in a different block.
That's bad.
I don't want to do that.
So when I find these
medians, or when I recurse,
I need that the medians
that I'm recursing on
are stored in a
contiguous array.
Now, this is easy to do.
But we didn't have to do before.
That's the key difference.
Make sure they are
stored contiguously.
I can do that because when I
sort each column in one scan,
I can have a second scan
which is the output, which
is the array of medians.
So as I'm scanning
through the input,
I'm going to output the median.
It's going to be 1/5 the size.
Then I've got all the
medians nicely stored
in a contiguous array.
So with order-one
parallel scans,
same time here, this is actually
a legitimate recursive call.
Then we partition.
Partition, again, is a bunch of
parallel scans, I think, three.
You've got one
reading scan, which
is you're reading
through the array,
and you've got to writing scans.
You're writing out the elements
less than or equal to x,
and you're writing out the
elements greater than x.
But again, all of
those are scans.
You're always writing
the next element right
after the previous one.
So if you already have
that block in memory
and if you assume that the
number of blocks in cache
is at least three, then
three parallel scans is fine.
It's different from the
CLRS partition algorithm.
That one was fancy
to be in place.
We're not trying to be
in place or fancy at all.
Let's just do it with
a bunch of scans.
So now we have two arrays--
the element less than x,
the elements greater than x.
Then we recurse on one of
them, and those elements
are consecutive
already, so good.
This is a regular
recursive call.
Again, we're
maintaining the variant
that the array is
stored contiguously.
And by the old analysis, that
array is sized at most 7/10 N.
So I get a new recurrence,
which is MT of N
is MT of N over 5 plus MT-- this
analysis feels very "empty--"
plus N over B-- sorry, bad
joke-- N over B plus 1.
So basically the same
recurrence, but now N over B
plus 1 for what
we're doing here.
But I had to change
the algorithm
a little bit for this
recurrence to be correct,
for it to correctly reflect
the number of memory transfers.
Now all we need to do
is solve the recurrence.
And actually, in some
sense, more importantly,
we need to figure out
what the base case is.
Because we could say, all right,
here's the usual base case.
If I have a
constant-sized problem,
well, that's going
to be constant.
This is our base case for every
recurrence we've ever done.
And that's enough usually.
It's going to give us a
really bad answer here.
So let's go off to the side
here and solve that recurrence.
So if that's my base case,
well, in particular-- so
this is some recursion tree.
It's very uneven, so it's
kind of annoying to draw.
But what I know
with this base case,
this overall MT event is
going to at least the number
of leaves in the recursion tree.
So let's say MT
of N is at least L
of N, number of leaves
in the recursion.
So this is really if
I run the algorithm,
how many base cases of
constant size do I get?
And that satisfies-- so it's
not obvious what that is.
There's no plus here.
Number of leaves is just how
many leaves are over here,
how many leaves are over here,
and L of 1 equals 1, say,
or some constant
equals constant.
I happen to know, because
I saw lots of recurrences,
this solves to some
N to the alpha.
I claim that L of N is N to the
alpha for some constant alpha.
Why?
I'll just prove that it works.
So this is now N
over 5 to the alpha,
and this is 7/10 N to the alpha.
If it's going to work, this
recurrence should be satisfied.
And now, if you look
at this equation,
there's a lot of N to the
alphas, and they all cancel.
So I get 1 equals 1/5 to the
alpha plus 7/10 to the alpha.
It's confusing
because I was just
watching the TV show
Alphas, but no relation.
So this is now something
purely in terms of alpha.
You just need to check that
there is a real solution.
There is one.
You have to plug it into
Wolfram Alpha or something,
no pun intended.
Wow, they're just
coming out today.
And then alpha is... next page...
I can't do this by hand.
Something like .83978.
So we get L of N is say at least N to the 0.8th bigger.
It's sublinear and that was enough when we cared about time
but now it's bad news because N over B...
our goal was to get N over B+1.
If B is huge, if B is bigger than N to the 0.2,
then we are not achieving this bound.
Right. We are always are paying at least N to the 0.8.
For example B is roughly N. We are way off!
But that's because we used the wrong base case.
Turns out if you use a better base case, things just work.
So let's do that. I think its going to be smaller.
So... the next base... I mean...
When you are doing cache full release analysis you never use this base case.
The first one you should think about is this one.
If you have a problem of size that fits in a constant number of blocks.
Well of course that's going to take... once they are read into the cache,
you are not going to pay anything.
How long does it take to read a constant number of blocks into cache?
Constant number of memory transfers.
Okay, this is obviously a strictly better base case than this one.
Because we have the same thing on the right hand side as a constant
but we've solved a larger problem.
So clearly you should cut here, instead of there.
Then the number of leaves
in this recursion...
So same recurrence- different base case.
So we'd stop recursing conceptually in the analysis, the algorithm goes all the way down,
but in the analysis we stop recursing when we reach a problem of size B.
The number of leaves in that new recursion tree will be
N over B to the alpha.
That's good! That's smaller than N over B.
OK, now I'm going
to wave my hands a little bit
and say, MT of N is
order N over B plus 1.
I guess to do that,
you want to prove it
the same way we did before
when we solved this recurrence,
which is by substitution.
You assume this is
true, you plug it in,
verify it can actually be
done with some constants.
The intuition of what's going on
is, in general, this recurrence
is dominated by the root.
The root cost for this
recursion is N over B plus 1.
So this is the root cost.
I claim that, up to
constant factors,
that is the overall cost.
Roughly because, as you go
down the recursion tree,
the cost is decreasing
geometrically.
But that's not obvious
for this recurrence
because it's so uneven.
But it's kind of like the
master method, a little fancier.
Intuitively, this
should be obvious.
There's the root cost and
then there's the other ones.
But to actually prove it, you
should do substitution method.
I want to go to more
interesting algorithms instead,
but any questions
before we continue?
All right.
So next algorithm,
that was median, now
we're going to do matrix
multiplication via divide
and conquer.
So what we just
saw was an example
where, in divide and
conquer, in the analysis
we think about the
case where things fit
in a constant number of blocks.
That was sort of case one.
The next example,
matrix multiplication,
will be the other case.
So you get to see both types.
So multiplying
matrices, something
we've done many times.
For example, in the FFT
lecture and in the Strassen's
algorithm, just to remind you.
I'm just thinking
about the square case,
although this generalizes.
We have two square
matrices, N by N.
Normally, I would say
C equals A times B,
but I realized we
used B for block side.
So this is going to
be s equals x times y.
Hopefully that doesn't conflict
with anything else, but no B's.
All right, so standard matrix.
Let's start with the
standard algorithm.
Let's start by analyzing that.
Because if you're
reasonably clever,
this the standard
algorithm is not so bad.
So in general, this
won't matter too much.
Let's suppose we're
doing z row-by-row,
and let's say we're currently
computing this product cell.
So that product cell
is the dot product
this ZIJ here is the dot product
of this row with this column.
How do I compute dot products?
Two parallel scans.
Right?
I scan through this
row and I parallel
scan through this column.
Now, it depends the order
in which you store x and y,
but let's suppose we can
store x in row major order,
meaning row-by-row, and we
store y in column major order,
meaning column-by-column.
Then this will be an
honest-to-goodness scan
of a contiguous array.
Again, the order we store
things in memory really matters.
So let's make our life ideal.
Let's say that
this is row-by-row
and this one is
column-by-column, then hey,
this is two parallel
scans so order N over B
to compute this cell.
OK, I claim that
computing ZIJ costs
N over B, so maybe plus 1.
Again, these are end-by-end
matrices, so total size N
squared, which means
the total cost is what?
N cubed over B plus
N squared, I guess.
Seems pretty good.
I mean, we had a running
time of N cubed before
and we divided by B. How
could you possibly do better?
Well, by being smarter.
This is not optimal,
you can do better.
It's not obvious,
but let me just spend
a little more time convincing
you this is the right answer.
Not only is this big O, but
for appropriate settings--
in the worst case this
is going to be theta.
Because if you think of the
order in which we're-- see,
we look at these
rows several times.
And if you look at, when I
compute this cell and this cell
and this cell of the z
matrix, or the product matrix,
each of them uses
the same row of x.
So maybe you could reuse that.
You could reuse that row of x.
That might actually
be free, depending
on how B and N relate.
But the columns of y, those
are different every time.
When I compute this one,
I use the first column
of y, when I compute this one
I use the second column of y.
Unless the cache
is so big that it
can store all of
y, which is like,
you could store the
entire problem in cache
that's unrealistic.
So unless M is bigger
than N squared,
in this algorithm at least, you
have to read a new column of y
every single time.
So that's why it's
theta N over B plus 1.
You need to spend
N over B, assuming
M is less than N squared.
OK.
And I claim this is not the
best you can do because we're
going to do better.
And we're going to do better
by divide and conquer.
Now, you've already seen
divide and conquer used
for matrix multiplication
to get Strassen's algorithm,
and the idea there
is to use blocks.
So this is sort of an
algorithm you've already seen.
I'm going to divide the
matrix z into N over 2
by N over 2 sub-matrices.
Each of these ZIJs is an N
over 2 by N over 2 matrix.
And I do the same
thing for x and y.
Numbers are right.
1, 2, y, 2, 1, and so on.
And you can write
this out explicitly.
I prefer not to do all of
it, but let's do one of them.
You can just think of these
as two-by-two matrices,
because matrix
multiplication is associative
and good things happen.
I can just take
these two elements--
but they're actually
matrices, sorry.
I might take these two and
dot product with these two.
And I get x1,1 y1,1
plus x1,2 y2,1,
and that's what I
should set z1,1 to.
So this is a formula, but it's
also a recursive algorithm.
It says, if I want to
compute z I'm going to say,
well, there are
four sub-problems.
The first one is
to compute z1,1,
and I'm going to do that
by recursively computing
the product of x1,1 and
y1,1, recursively computing
the product of x1,2 y2,1 and
then adding them together.
This is not recursive.
Addition is easy.
OK.
And there's two products
here, two products here,
two products here,
a total of eight
products, so we're
going to have eight recursive
calls in size N over 2.
If we look at the number
of memory transfers,
this is 8 times recursive
call on N over 2 by N
over 2 sub-matrices plus
the cost of addition.
And I claim the cost of addition
is at most N squared over B
plus 1, because addition is
basically parallel scans.
I can scan through
x, scan through y.
As long as they're
stored in the same order,
I just am adding them
element by element,
and there's a third scan, which
is writing out the z vector
once things are linearized.
Now, for this to work, for
this to be a true recursion,
I need that, say, x1,1 and y1,1
are stored as contiguous things
in memory.
So this means that the
layout of a matrix,
let's consider the matrix z, is
going to be like the following.
I'm going to recursively lay
out 1,1-- so when I say lay out,
I mean what order do I store
the elements in memory?
What order do I store
the cells in memory?
And what I'm going to say
is, recursively lay out
the pieces-- there's four
pieces-- recursively call
layout of those and then
concatenate them together.
That's my layout.
So I'm going to store
all of these items,
then I'm going to store
and then all of these
items, then all these items.
How do I store these
items, in what order?
Recursively.
So I'm going to
divide them like this,
store these before these
before these before these,
how do I store these?
Recursively.
OK, same recursion.
So it's a really
weird order, it's
a divide and conquer order.
There's only four things here.
In what order should I
combine the four things?
Doesn't matter.
All that matters is that
this is consecutive,
and this is consecutive,
so that when I recurse, I'm
recursing on consecutive chunks
of memory.
Otherwise the analysis
just won't work.
So for this to be right,
got to have this layout.
OK.
Now we just need to solve the
recurrence, and we're done.
I already told you, the
base case we're going to use
is this one.
We're going to use
this one because it's
stronger and better, and
we'll need it, in this case,
to get a better analysis.
You could solve it using
the weaker base cases,
you'll get larger numbers.
But if you use the strongest
base case, MT of-- it's
not M. Got to be
a little careful.
Because N here is actually
just one side length.
This is an end-by-end
matrix, so the total size
is N squared-- actually the
total size is 3N squared,
so this is going to be the
square root of M over 3,
at some constant, times the
square root of N. It actually
doesn't matter what
the constant is.
But this is the
size of-- this is
the value of N for which
all three matrices will
fit in cache.
So I claim we know this costs at
most M over B memory transfers,
because we were kind of
stroke here because we know
that all of these
guys fit in cache
and because we know that they
can store it consecutively
in memory, well three
consecutive chunks.
Once, no matter what I do, there
are only M over B blocks there,
and so at worst I
read them all in.
But once the cache
is filled with them,
for the duration
of this recursion,
I won't be reading
any other blocks,
and so the cache will just
stay full with the problem.
And so I never pay
more than this.
So that's the base case.
Easy, but you have to think
about it for a second.
Cool.
Now we have a recurrence
and a base case,
and now we have a good old
fashioned recursion tree.
This one I can actually
draw, because it's-- well,
partly because it's
nice and uniform.
It just explodes rather fast.
So at the top we have a cost
of N squared over B plus 1,
and we have eight
recursive calls.
And the recursive calls
are to something in size
N over 2 squared over B, also
known as N squared over 4B.
OK, so if I add up
everything on this level,
I get N squared over B, and if I
add up everything on this level
I'm going to get 8 times
N over 4-- is that right?
Yeah.
So 2 times N squared over B.
OK.
I did that in order to verify
that the cost per level
is increasing geometrically,
so all that will matter
is the leaf level.
This is the proof of
the master theorem.
When things are
doubling at every step--
and this was just
a special case,
but every level would look
the same-- every level
of recursion, if
you add them all up,
you're getting twice as much as
you had at the previous level.
So all that will matter
is the leaf level.
OK, the leaf level.
Actually, maybe I'll
do it over here.
First question is how
many leaves are there?
The leaves are this thing.
So the way I would think about
this is, because everything
is nice and uniform, is 8 to the
power of the number of levels.
What's the number of levels?
Well, we're dividing
by 2 each time,
so it's going to be
log of something,
but it's no longer log N
because we're stopping early.
We're stopping when
N reaches this value.
So it turns out that is
N divided by that value.
This is, how many
times do I have
to multiply by 2 before
I get to this, which
is the same thing as how many
times do I have to divide N
by 2 before I get that?
Think about it.
OK, but 8 to the log.
This is 2 to the 3 times log.
2 to the log is just the thing.
So this is N over root M
over B-- so many overs--
to the third power.
OK, this is starting
to look familiar.
This is N cubed, that
should appear somewhere,
divided by square
root of M over B.
This is the number of leaves.
Now, for each leaf
we're paying this cost,
so the overall cost of MT of N
is going to be this times this.
So let's do that and simplify.
So MT of N is going to be big
O, because we're taking the leaf
level but there's some
other things that's just
going to lose us a factor of 2.
We have this thing
multiplied by this thing.
So we've got N cubed over
square root of M over B
times M over B.
AUDIENCE: You--
PROFESSOR: I made a mistake.
Yea, thank you.
This was supposed to be cubed.
So this was M over B to
the 1/2, so now we have,
down here, M over B to the 3/2.
Thank you, thought
that looked weird.
All right.
M over B to the 3/2.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What was I doing here?
This is supposed to be M over 3.
I was not missing a
stroke, thank you.
M over 3, this is
supposed to be M over 3.
Wow.
OK, so this is M over 3.
I'm just going to drop the--
well, I'll put it here.
But then I'm just
going to write theta
so I can forget about the
3, because that's just
a square root of 3 factor.
So now this is going
to be M to the 3/2.
That makes me much happier.
Did I get it right this time?
Let's double-check.
So this is square root
of M to the 3 power,
so that's M to the 1/2
cubed M to the 3/2.
I think that's good, this base
case was square root of M.
OK, get it right.
So now this is M to the 3/2.
There is a square
root that's going
to come back, there's M to the
3/2 and there's an M upstairs,
so the one cancels.
We're going to be left with
N cubed over square root of M
times B. OK.
There was a lower order term
because I dropped this plus 1,
but let's not worry
about that right now.
Here we had N cubed
divided by B, that
was the standard algorithm.
Now we've got M cubed divided by
B divided by square root of M.
That's big.
I mean, this is
basically, you're
dividing by-- well, square
root of your cache size.
Wow.
So who knows how big
that is, but say,
between memory and disk,
we're talking gigabytes.
So this is like billions.
Square root of a billion
is still pretty big,
like 10 to 100,000, so this
is a huge amount faster
than the standard algorithm.
You can do way
better than scans.
Basically because we're reusing
the same rows and columns
over and over.
Now, this is standard
matrix multiplication.
You might ask, what about
Strassen's algorithm?
Well, same thing works.
You can do the same analysis
Strassen, of course.
You get a similar
improvement over Strassen.
You can do this for
non-square matrices and all
those good things.
And one minute left.
And it's going to
be enough, I think,
to cover LRU block replacement.
So here's what I want to say
about LRU block replacement.
So in the beginning, we
said the model is LRU,
or it could have been FIFO.
Remember that?
And this algorithm will
work just fine from an LRU
perspective or a
FIFO perspective
if you think about
it, but how do
we know that LRU is
as good as anything?
I claim, if you look at some
sequence of block axises--
so suppose you know what
B is-- and you count,
for a cache of size M, how many
memory transfers does LRU do,
it's going to be within a
factor of 2 of the optimal.
But not the optimal
for a cache of size M,
the optimal for a
cache of size M over 2.
This is a bit of
a weird statement.
I have a factor of 2 here
and a factor of 2 here.
This is a cool idea called
resource augmentation,
fancy word for a simple idea.
This we're used to.
This is approximation
algorithms.
OK, but this is an
approximation in cost.
Here we're approximating
the resources
available to the algorithm.
We're changing the machine
model, dividing M by 2,
and we get a nice result.
Why is this OK?
Because, if you look
at a bound like this,
if you change M
by a factor of 2,
it will not change the
bound by more than a
factor of square root of 2.
So as long as you
have at most, say,
a linear or polynomial
dependence on M,
changing M by a
constant factor will not
change the overall
running time of the cache
for the previous algorithm.
This is why we can
assume it's LRU.
The same is true for
FIFO, it's probably
true in expectation
for random sequences.
And I will leave it at that.
If you want to see
the-- do you want
to see the proof
of this theorem?
Tomorrow?
Or, Thursday?
Yes.
OK, we'll cover it on Thursday.